[Música]
é bom que é como vocês puderam perceber
eu gosto muito de música e por isso
escolhi o tema o poder da música em
nossas vidas e também por isso eu
resolvi aprender a tocar piano n se a
minha palestra e tocando como vocês
viram as músicas podem trazer diferentes
sentimentos por exemplo as músicas que
eu toquei trazem um sentimento diferença
a primeira música que eu toquei chamada
por elise é romântica então traz uma
sensação de calma
já a segunda música que eu toquei que é
o tema de star wars deixa as pessoas
mais animadas
os diferentes sentimentos que a música
traz podem ajudar na cura e na
recuperação de pessoas que estão doentes
isso é o que mais nos chama a atenção na
música porque é uma forma de ajudar as
pessoas
bom agora vou mostrar um exemplo prático
eu tenho uma amiga chamada cléo que eu
conheço há muito tempo desde que
tínhamos três anos
infelizmente ela tem um problema chamado
mav o que causou nela 2 avc's quando
tinha 4 anos e 1 quando tinha 11 anos
por isso ela ficou internada no hospital
por um tempo e nesse período alguns
organismos foram tocar algumas músicas
para ela e para a família
será que só ajuda a não ser que a mãe
dela aqui não vêm a seguir
eu sou mãe da trel do ano passado a
criança teve um problema de saúde
ficar internada por 25 dias durante esse
tempo ocorreram dois episódios que a
gente tem uma experiência de música no
ambiente hospitalar
a primeira vez foi na uti ea segunda vez
foi no quarto é eram pessoas que estavam
cantando músicas de conteúdo religioso
que falava de deus que falava de
esperança falava de fé falava de
superação e isso foi muito bacana pra
gente
acho que as pessoas que estão vivendo
uma situação de doença ou acompanhando
um familiar doente então com o coração
fragilizado né emocionalmente
fragilizada
então isso ajuda bastante foi muito bom
pra mim ela estava sedada não se lembra
exatamente de tudo o que aconteceu mas
tenho certeza que mesmo sem ter essa
consciência fez muito bem para ela
também
é acho que ajuda muitas pessoas numa
situação dessa né reconforta então foi
uma experiência muito positiva que a
gente teve mesmo com relação à música
teve uma outra situação também em que
quando ela já estava começando a
recobrar a consciência eu ligava ao
tablet mostrava o vídeo de algumas
músicas que ela gosta ela se animava
muito inclusive até tentar fazer uma
coreografia uma dancinha assim meio que
deitada então era um fator animador para
ela com certeza as estatísticas também
comprovam isso
como podemos ver no gráfico a música
pode trazer diversos benefícios mas o
que ela mais ajuda é na redução do nível
de ansiedade nas pessoas ocupando 43% na
distribuição do gráfico
então nós podemos concluir que a música
traz amor é única para cada um de nós
gera sorrisos e alegria a 40 nossos
corações e ajuda na cura de pessoas que
estão doentes e deprimidas
então eu acho que devemos usar a música
quem não são ambientes hospitalares mas
também ambiente do nosso cotidiano
então já que a moça é tão poderosa nada
melhor do que acabar a minha
apresentação tocando uma
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
obrigada pela atenção
[Música]